noisy Dusty making garments all these
bales of fabric it creates a lot of dust
can make it quite hard to breathe rows
and rows of machinists people packing
clothes people snipping loose threads
off clothes lots and lots of people
working from dawn to dusk even before it
collapsed the Rana plaza building in
Bangladesh was an unpleasant place to
work
the Garment workers mostly women had
complained about the conditions in the
factories but were made to continue
working even though managers knew the
building was unsafe there were basically
too many floors there were too many
people packed into that building there
was too many machineries and too many
bales of cloth
just the day before cracks had appeared
in the building
and shops and a bank on the lower floors
were evacuated
the following morning garment workers
stood outside in protest but they were
made to return to work
at nine in the morning
that concrete Came Crashing Down burying
hundreds of workers on the 24th of April
2013 the tower Block in Bangladesh
collapsed
it killed
1134 people and left thousands more with
life-changing injuries
for people in the UK and around the
world the Rana Plaza disaster brought to
their attention perhaps for the first
time just how their clothes were being
made and their outrage made fashion
brands promise to do better what we saw
at Rana Plaza is proof that the fashion
industry values the clothes that it
makes more than it values the lives of
the people who make them a decade on how
much has the fashion industry really
changed
I'm Sally Lockwood and this is the Sky
News Daily
the
the factory
Plex was an H orry building in an area
of Dhaka called Sava in Bangladesh and
within that eight stories there were
five different garment factories tansy
Hoskins is a journalist and writer who's
written extensively on the fashion
industry for her book the
anti-capitalist book of fashion she
spoke to survivors of the runner Plaza
collapse about what happened that day it
was an extremely unsafe building there
were basically too many floors there
were too many people packed into that
building there was too many machineries
and too many bales of cloth
so on the morning before the the
building collapsed uh cracks appeared in
Rana Plaza and other uh premises that
were in that building were evacuated
the next morning when the workers came
to work they pointed out the cracks they
they said that the building was
dangerous and they said they didn't want
to go to work and so there was a an
argument on the forecourt between the
managers of the Garment factories and
between the workers and eventually the
managers said if you don't go in and go
to work we're going to dock you A
month's pay and you can imagine losing a
month's pay for a garment worker in
Bangladesh is is an impossibility most
of these workers were young women most
of them were supporting families so
people were forced to go into this
building a few hours later the
supporting pillars cracked and in about
90 seconds the entire building
fell in upon itself leading to the death
of
1138 people and injury both physical and
psychological of many thousands more
foreign
this was on the worst instances of
industrial homicide ever and is one of
the worst unintended structural failures
of a building in modern history and it
happened right at the heart of the
fashion industry
this event was so significant and so
shocking
because it emerged that clothing for big
high street names here in the UK and in
other Western countries was being made
in this Factory where safety was being
so disregarded and workers were being
quite clearly exploited yes you're
totally right like if you walk down you
know a sort of typical British High
Street and you pass you know the shops
that were at Rana Plaza that were at
that time in manufacturing so Primark
Matalan Benetton mango and then CNA
which many of us remember and then you
know from overseas Walmart The
Children's Place were amongst the brands
what do you know about how much big
Brands and retailers knew what was going
on when it came to the conditions in
these factories an extraordinary thing
that emerged is that Primark went on to
admit that it had done two safety audits
of Rana Plaza and that they had decided
that that building was a perfectly safe
and viable place for them to be
manufacturing clothes so yes I you know
at Primark quite clearly you know knew
what Factory they were Manufacturing in
but also Charities and garment workers
had been warning for a while that
something like this could happen hadn't
they it was really frustrating because
many many people both in Bangladesh and
around the world had been saying that
something like Rana Plaza was going to
happen it wasn't the first disaster in
Bangladesh there had been
you know a string of factory fires and I
think you know trade unions in
Bangladesh and campaigners around the
world just felt like the industry was
not listening to what people were saying
about how unsafe so many of these
factories were and you know even after
Rana Plaza happened you know even after
you've got over a thousand dead bodies
the industry was really not in my
opinion very good at responding in the
way that it should have like it took two
years of really quite rigorous
campaigning and and you know and people
writing articles and holding protests
and really sort of pressuring CEOs like
two years to get compensation for the
the people in the family who were caught
up in this like tragedy and like I'm
sure we'll go on to talk about the
Bangladesh Accord but many of the brands
had to be dragged Kicking and Screaming
to the table to sign up to like to even
just the most basic safety precautions
in their factories what has actually
changed since the main thing that
happened was that for the first time in
the fashion industry you had a legally
binding agreement on Factory safety
which was the Bangladesh Accord on uh
Fire and Building Safety it has
definitely worked it meant that there
were inspections of over 1600 factories
and
I have no doubt that without the
Bangladesh Accord there would have been
more Rana plazas uh you know some of the
the things that the the inspections
uncovered were horrendous buildings
where there were no fire escapes and
where there were crashes on like you
know on the 10th floor and things like
this like structurally unsound buildings
where thousands of people were working
so yeah I have no doubt that the
Bangladesh Accord saved tens of
thousands of lives
the Bangladesh Accord has as you say
improved safety conditions but
exploitation still exists explain to us
how much that is still a problem and
What needs to change there
yes you are I mean you're completely
right I mean it's this for me is one of
the big tragedies of Rana Plaza is that
this was supposed to be the watershed
moment in which the fashion industry
truly changed but the the truth of the
matter is that yes while the buildings
are safer conditions for workers have
not truly changed garment workers in
Bangladesh do not earn a decent minimum
wage they do not earn a living wage at
all so at the moment workers are paid 75
U.S American dollars per month and what
would actually be a living wage would be
about three times that much so people
are still extremely poor the right to
have a Trade union or to have any kind
of freedom of Association in factories
is still incredibly restricted and what
we saw over the pandemic and what we've
repeatedly seen is that when garment
workers try to stand up for themselves
you know try to get a better wage is
that the the Bangladeshi state gets
involved and responds very heavily so
you know we continuously see workers
being shot dead during protests and
workers being arrested during protests
and workers being beaten up both by um
sort of hired Thugs and the police in
Bangladesh so yeah it's it's not a good
situation at all there's still so much
that that needs to be improved
what are retailers and big Brands doing
about this treatment of workers workers
that are being paid 75 a month who want
to protest their rights uh making a lot
of money essentially like not yeah like
not much that they can be proud of in in
my opinion still many Brands don't want
to sign up to the to the Accord they
still kind of relying upon like
voluntary certification schemes you know
they're not in the corner of the workers
they're not in the corner of trade
Unions that's not why they're in
Bangladesh like they're in Bangladesh to
you know make maximum profit to make
their shareholders happy you know it's
really the bottom line that comes first
in the fashion industry
[Music]
I mean I've been working for mother of
pearl for 16 years actually
um showing my age Amy palny is the
creative director of sustainable fashion
brand mother of pearl and she also
campaigns for a fairer and Greener
fashion industry I guess I've always
been passionate about sustainability and
ethics when I was at University I sort
of knew quite a lot about Sweatshop
issues ETC and but kind of as my career
progressed as did Fast fashion and the
sheer consumption and the way we produce
and climate change is you know becoming
a bigger topic within the industry
because of its impact and so I guess the
more I was following the more knowledge
I had the more I was learning the more I
was becoming very uneasy with the
industry that I was in I just couldn't
do it anymore actually and it was really
kind of make a change or or break away
and so I decided to set out on a
challenge to see if I could make the
brands sustainable it blows my mind that
you could buy a dress in the UK for less
than a tenor that's made in Bangladesh
explain to us what's involved in that
garment arriving here in the UK and
being sold so cheaply yeah so let's
suggest It's a cotton piece let's look
at the Cotton farmers and the cotton
Pickers so they need to obviously grow a
crop and pick it and if we're talking
about 10 pound dress to ours and the
markup that a let's say High Street
store has put on so they wouldn't be if
they're selling it for 10 pounds that
means they bought it let's say for five
pounds it's not always the mass but
let's say it is so we're talking about
five pounds worth of supply chain you've
got to pay a farmer you've got to pay a
spinner a weaver and a manufacturer and
all the shipping and transportation and
packaging in between it I mean if you
just break that down potentially into
five stages and then you talk about one
pound per stage which also isn't how it
works but just as a kind of overview
that means
potentially and we're talking Pence that
these people are getting paid and so how
on Earth can we could people live like
that
and I think something that you know many
people may not realize is that
some Brands don't even bother trying to
resell clothing that's been returned to
them because it's just not worth their
while and they end up burning it or
throwing it away I mean the waste is
huge yes I think we look at the Brand
level people because it's so cheap
getting something back reprocessing it
putting it back to a warehouse and
reselling it is more expensive than the
item itself so they're burning it and it
kind of shows how little we're paying
for these garments and and kind of what
the value of them are to us as consumers
and to brands
a lot of big brands are also now trying
to emulate what you've done with mother
of pearl trying to be more sustainable
more environmentally friendly realizing
that a lot of consumers now care about
that too how much is that working and
how much is it green washing
um it's a very good question I would say
for the most part unfortunately it is
green washing that doesn't sort of
suggest that people's intentions aren't
necessarily good I mean obviously we
know in some big corporations they're
not and but I think in some other brands
they are I just think the sheer
complexity of Supply chains and just the
sheer consumption that's happening
fashion just to clarify the term
greenwashing is used to describe
companies which effectively make claims
to sustainability for example in fashion
by advertising their use of recycled
materials in their clothing but in
reality their brand isn't as
eco-friendly as they make out
so Amy how do fashion brands go about
making real change we have to talk about
degrowth we have to talk about
restructuring your entire business we
have to rethink the entire fashion
industry and so I think a lot of people
are suggesting that they're making
sustainable collections Etc by buying
let's say a slightly better fiber but
it's just not enough and it's that's a
kind of tiny sticky plaster it's like
carbon offsetting people talk about that
and you know they're just small ways to
slightly improve things and it's
systemic change we really need so
unfortunately a lot of it is just not
not good enough and not big enough
you know some may say well if these
people in Bangladesh didn't work for
these garment factories they may not
work at all yeah I mean that is a very
good point and
um I talk about this a lot because I
think you know if you ask a lot of
people in these Supply chains this job
or no job they were plead for this job
because it's a way to survive so I don't
think the answer is just simply to kind
of stop everything we need systemic
change and we need legislation and we
need things to happen kind of
incrementally because yeah for sure you
know if you there's been an instant in
my life where I found out a cotton Farm
you know had children picking the cotton
and you're you're kind of instinct is
instantly to you know I have children
myself you think oh my God how can this
happen but the truth is those children
probably don't have a school to go to
they don't have anywhere else to go to
and that probably is their livelihood
for the rest of their lives so we can't
take away the value that these jobs have
for these people because
they need that as much as we need our
jobs so it's not completely just
stopping it's about paying the correct
money for what we've got and I think
there's a balance and a shift that you
know if we paid more but produce less we
would see those you know nothing needs
to change because people could work less
hours you could be producing better
quality we could have less than a
footprint but we could still be paying
the correct money so there is a way to
balance it but it is very complicated
you know it sounds simple but it's
economic it's International and it's
political as much as anything else
yeah totally like like so many things
it's not one-dimensional at all but for
listeners who maybe want to do their
bits and try and be more sustainable
what would be your advice to them in
terms of how to support the industry to
be more ethical and more environmentally
friendly so there's many many many ways
just some quick ones are I always say
but try to buy less and buy better so
buy that I talk about you know buying
from Brands they're all kind of being
traceable and
um explaining to you what you know what
they're doing and kind of how their
systems and Supply chains work if you
can if you are going to buy from Big
High Street Brands because that is what
you can afford you know send messages
back to those CEOs and those Boards of
what you want from them so whether
that's emailing them and calling them
asking them questions or if they do have
a conscious line or a more sustainable
line although for the most part A lot of
it is brainwashing in a way by buying
those ones you are still sending
messages back up to the boardroom that
that is the type of product people are
wanting which means maybe they'll invest
more money and more of their lines into
those better practices there's also
buying second hand which I think is
becoming a more interesting market and
more exciting and more fashionable and
more sort of chic and cool and not kind
of you know charity shop esque which is
what people have seen in the past so I
think there's a lot of exciting things
happening in that space and I know as a
mother in children's clothes and that's
what I do and it gives me so much joy
and pleasure because I don't feel guilty
when I'm purchasing the clothes even if
it is from a High Street brand like a
Zara or whatnot because it's secondhand
I still feel like I can be playful and
fun and the guilt is removed because I
haven't bought it you know first hand so
I'd say they're this sort of quickest
and easiest and simplest ways and to do
better and do better sounds negative I
don't mean it like that but you know I
think there's still ways to love fashion
enjoy it but just to be more considered
about what we do and to think about
different ways to do it
my thanks to Amy poorney and tansy
Hoskins and to you for listening to the
Sky News Daily with me Sally Lockwood
this episode was produced by Rosie
Gillett with Alex Eden our editor is
Philly Beaumont
foreign foreign